in front of me i have the brand new
razer blade advance with the 12th
generation intel processor and today
we're going to compare to the 16-inch
macbook pro and everything from the
displays design the speakers the webcam
the cpu performance graphics performance
as well as real world tasks such as
photo editing video editing and more and
we're gonna find out once and for all
who makes the best laptop for 2
500
here are the full specs side by side
they are very similar but the razer
gives us double the storage we'll see
just how fast that is and of course we
have an intel processor with 14 cores 20
threads and an rtx 3060 graphics card
with six gigs of memory
size wise they are almost identical the
razer actually sits a little bit higher
off of your desk just because as fans on
the bottom and it needs bigger feet to
maintain the airflow whereas the macbook
has vents on the bottom side that don't
get blocked as easily now we also have a
difference of internal battery the razer
has a 80 watt hour battery compared to
100 on the macbook and along with the
differences in efficiencies the battery
life difference is pretty dramatic and
with that the macbook has a magsafe
charger 140 watt or you can use the usb
type-c to charge and that's because it
doesn't need that much power it's very
efficient i believe it doesn't use over
80 watts total peak power in this
configuration whereas the razer has a
230 watt brick and of course it does
need that power for that cpu that has a
bunch of cores and the graphics and it's
gonna be interesting to see how it
performs later we're gonna do
performance tests and also unplug and
see how much performance we lose as far
as ports apple finally added some back
this year but the razer still one ups
the macbook with three usb a ports which
is really nice to have
and the macbook does have one extra
thunderbolt that the razer doesn't now
one thing i absolutely love about the
razer is windows
soaking
hello
you guys saw that right there just
logged me in automatically and with the
macbook even though we have this giant
notch right there apple didn't really
make use of it and it's a bummer of
course we do have touch id it works but
it's not as great as windows hello i
really wish they added face id now as
far as the keyboards and the track pads
the razer actually does a pretty decent
job they've really improved in the last
few years especially on the trackpad but
it still is a diving board design so
it's a lot harder almost impossible to
press at the top and easy at the bottom
whereas the macbook has that force touch
that can be adjusted it's perfectly even
it is larger there nobody argues that
macbooks have the best track pads and
the keyboard also this newer design that
they've had last couple years is a
little bit better than the razer but i
don't think anybody's going to complain
if they buy one of these now we have a
lot of differences in terms of the
displays and we're going to cover that
in just a sec but first i want to
compare the sound quality razer's had
this thx logo here for a little bit last
time i listened to one i was
disappointed
but let's go ahead and see if they've
made some improvements compared to the
amazing speaker system with woofers in
the 16-inch macbook pro
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys wow let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below i was not expecting that the razer
is super loud compared to the macbook
it's quite a bit louder now it's mostly
highs and what i think they did is turn
down the mids and really turn down the
bass and crank up those highs because
the bass is pretty much non-existent now
the macbook it's quieter but man the
bass is there so much richer so much
more of a natural high quality sound and
before the razer actually sounded
decently balanced it was just really
quiet now i think that for usability if
you just need to hear something it might
be good to have that option and i did
turn on the improved audio quality in
the settings uh so definitely the
macbook sounds a lot better but i'm glad
that they turned the razer from a really
quiet machine to one that is much louder
and usable now comparing the displays we
do have quite a bit of differences the
razer display is actually quite nice
it's a 1440p panel and it is 240 hertz
refresh rate so it's nice and smooth
perfect for gaming now the macbook this
thing is a 120 hertz pro motion so that
means it has the ability to slow down to
60 hertz and even lower to save battery
life and that really helps whereas the
razer you're either doing 240 or 60. now
on top of that even though the regular
brightness is 500 nits it can reach up
to a thousand six hundred for hdr
content versus the razer which they
don't give out any specs but it looks
like it's about 350 to 400 nits the
macbooks display is definitely more
color accurate with a lot of different
profiles depending on what you want to
do so if you're somebody that's doing
creative work the macbook screen is
definitely nicer but that doesn't mean
that people might won't buy the razer a
lot of people do for serious work and
here is the quality of razer's 1080p
webcam and dual front-facing microphones
overall to me it looks good but you guys
let me know what you see and this is the
macbook's 1080p camera with studio
quality microphones let me know which
one looks better and which one sounds
better and now let's get into
performance starting with an ssd speed
test i have the same program at the same
settings opened up on both
and look at that both of these are
incredibly fast in terms of read with
the razers one terabyte ssd beating out
the macbook by about 900 megabytes per
second but the mac as far as right is
quite a bit faster about a thousand
three hundred megabytes per second
faster for the right and then of course
if you do get a one terabyte model it's
going to cost you
an extra 200 bucks and then both of
these do kick up quite a bit because
this is the smallest configuration now i
went ahead and plugged in the razer and
i also went into the window settings to
make sure it set the best performance as
well as the razer synapse settings i
made sure everything is set to the
highest performance we don't need to be
buying a performance machine and having
it running at half power and one thing i
noticed when i was setting up this razor
system was just how snappy it was
much quicker than any windows laptop
that i've used before probably because
that 12th gen cpu so now i'm running
speedometer 2.0 this is going to test
how quick and snappy this system is all
right wow that is the highest score
of any windows laptop or windows desktop
i have seen
our mac has 274 points or runs per
minute
incredible performance super snappy way
faster than my mac pro
this thing has 257 so a little bit
behind
but not much at all and this thing is
way snappier than the previous razer we
tested a few months ago now i'm gonna
unplug it and test it again because if
you didn't know razer on battery power
limits you to be in balanced mode only
all right not bad it did go down but
it's still above
what amd's best processors get in their
laptops when they're plugged in so 209
is an excellent score and then 257 if
you have it plugged in and i did have
the windows performance settings set to
maximum so far i'm really impressed with
this 14 core
alder lake processor but now let's jump
into geekbench i have it plugged back in
again and let's see what kind of
performance we get with a wide variety
of tasks both single core and multi-core
alright guys once again wow this is very
impressive for two different reasons
first off the single core score actually
beats out the macbook pro by just a tiny
bit with a margin of error basically but
it's right there no wonder it's so
snappy when i was setting stuff up and
the multi-core score while it does not
beat out the m1 pro it is still very
very close about 500 points away that's
pretty much insignificant you're not
going to notice that difference day to
day and with that
even though i did hear the fans spin up
they barely spun up compared to the
previous generation razer laptops that
would get loud and they'd spin up their
fans so quite impressive but now let's
check out cinebench r23 that's going to
max out the cpus maybe this thing will
get loud while the macbook still stays
silent and on battery power i'm starting
the 10 minute test here plugged in and
let's see
wow all right we're getting 90 watts of
cpu power used here in a laptop that is
incredible the temperature is already at
90 degrees celsius and we're running at
about 3.6 gigahertz or so
and almost right away we dropped down to
54 watts just because of thermals and
about 2.8 2.7 gigahertz compared to 3.2
gigahertz on the m1 pro now this thing
is unplugged it doesn't thermal throttle
the fans won't even go more than half
speed if you max out the cpu and gpu at
the same time running at 3.2 and only
pulling 30 watts maximum now the fans
are on i hear them but they're not
excessive using our thermal cam we can
see that we have a ton of hot area there
45 46 degrees celsius with that bar
compared to our macbook 37 at the max
right there actually on the display
whereas the exhaust is coming out
meaning the macbook runs silently and
quite a bit cooler as well alright guys
wow
that is close right there we have
12
620 for the razer compared to 12 375 so
yes in 400 cpu performance plugged in
the razer does beat the mac but even
though in geekbench 5's multi-global
score it actually lost by about 500
points very impressive that was a 10
minute stress test now i do want to run
that one more time i'm not gonna run the
full uh 10 minute test but i do want to
run just one quick test we'll see what
kind of difference we get if you're
running on battery power and how much
limitations the cpu has alright wow it
looks like on battery power this 14 core
processor is running right around the
same amount of wattage as our macbook
pro we're getting about 30 watts 31 31.5
just slightly higher than this mac it's
going to be interesting to see what
performance we get both on battery both
the same wattage intel 12th gen alder
lake versus apple silicon
m1 pro and here we go look at that score
take a guess down below what you think
it got running at the same exact wattage
or just slightly higher than the wattage
of the macbook pro
we're getting
7952 points that means that it's a
pretty significant drop in the macbook
is about 56 percent more powerful so a
lot of people talking about alder lake
its efficiencies when you down clock it
you running at lower wattage it still
performs very well and it does decently
enough and part of this is razer's
software and what they're doing
but the macbook gives you all that
performance on battery power as well
now of course the cpu isn't everything
we also have graphics so i'm going to
run 3d marks wildlife extreme unlimited
tests so we are not limited by
resolution to keep it fair and let's see
what kind of performance differences we
get with these graphics paired to the
cpu and look at that razer is fighting
back now
with that nvidia graphics card scoring
16 248 compared to a nice score but much
lower 10 432 so the razer when it's
plugged in is about 55 more powerful in
terms of graphics performance for gaming
and other tasks and then on battery
power that drops
a lot more than double to 7747
about 35 slower than the macbook on
battery so quite a swing there now i
know some of you guys say hey this is a
performance laptop you should always
have a plug-in why would you not have it
plugged in
for example on an airplane if you're
traveling or if you don't have an outlet
nearby and sometimes it's just nice not
to have to so i appreciate that the
macbook gives you full performance and
also the fact that you can charge it
with a cheap 40 usb c bank and it'll
actually run your laptop and charge at
the same time as you're working on it
alright guys and now let's get into some
other real world tests yes i look a
little bit different we're having
hardware issues from the audio recorders
to our servers so this is another day
but in front of me i have lightroom open
and this is where i'm excited to see how
the performance of this 12 gen stacks up
to the apple silicon chip i have 50 high
resolution raw images opened up here
that have effects added so every time i
switch to a new photo all those effects
have to be added on and processed and as
you guys could see
the mac is surprisingly faster even
though the single core performance is so
so close now that also has something to
do with the memory apple uses their
unified memory that's right there right
on the same chip as the m1 pro
you guys can see this is what we had
before
and apple is still ahead here let's test
out the brush performance this is
something that slows down the system
especially if you're using a lot of
effects or changes you guys saw that
right there we had a little bit of
stutter right at the beginning
try that again
yep a little bit of stuttering it's
pretty extreme right here let's see if
the razor is smoother
nope actually a little bit more
stuttering now you wouldn't do this much
of an exposure change but that does show
that we have a little bit more
smoothness with the macbook i'm going to
go ahead and undo that brush and i'm
going to select all 50 of these images
and let's go ahead and export these i'm
going to start my timer here and i have
to say i'm a little bit surprised i was
expecting the razer to beat out the mac
but let's see how long this export takes
right off the bat the mac is taking the
lead it started it almost instantly the
fans did ramp up though on the razor
right away all right it looks like it's
starting to catch up and just to make
sure i checked and made sure everything
is set to maximum performance all right
we are done here
go ahead and guess how long each system
took all right the razor took two
minutes flat it's cooling down right now
the macbook took a minute and 23 seconds
not twice as fast but a heck a lot
faster so imagine if you had a hundred
photos a thousand photos or two thousand
if you're a wedding photographer that
definitely makes a difference that just
shows you that raw performance doesn't
really tell the whole story and now
let's get into video editing i have this
five minute 4k project with a couple
different luts applied both of these
systems are gonna have no issue editing
4k even with multicam and different
effects so let's go ahead and export
this project i am using the nvidia
encoders here which are much faster than
the built-in quick sync ones let's hit
render and right away our mac is
exporting at about 89 to 90 frames per
second while our razer is running at
about 71. and it looks like the graphics
card is actually the limitation it's 100
maxed out so it's not the encoders it's
the actual gpu performance where in like
the gaming tests we saw that the gpu was
much faster than this and the razer took
a minute and 45 seconds to export
compared to a minute and 21 for the mac
so once again just like lightroom we're
seeing this pretty big difference in
terms of real world projects and keep in
mind the razer if we unplug it it's now
exporting at about 29 30 frames per
second instead of 70 where the mac
unplugged running the same exact and
that took 7 minutes and 36 seconds
compared to still a minute and 21 on the
mac now of course the razer does have
more raw performance so let's go ahead
and stabilize a clip this is a one
minute clip here and that will just show
us the performance when you're rendering
analyzing using all of that graphics
horsepower and here the razer took 32
seconds compared to the mac taking 39
seconds on this one minute clip so as
far as raw horsepower the razer is still
a little bit ahead but nothing like that
huge lead we saw in gaming now i do want
to do a more detailed video editing test
if enough of you guys care about that
because there are so many codecs of
course the mac has prores decoders and
encoders built in we also have raw
codecs like red black magic so if you
guys want to see that let me know down
below so overall guys here you go intel
did a great job with the 12th gen cpus
razer did a good job this thing is
cooler it is quieter uh it's a much
nicer system than before if you're
gaming of course this is the way to go
but if you're somebody doing video
editing photo editing different
productivity and if you're somebody who
cares about performance on battery and
battery life we do have a pretty big
difference the display is a lot nicer
for people who are doing that kind of
work so you guys let me know your
thoughts which one would you buy who
makes the best laptop for 2500 as an
apple or is it razer check out one of
those great videos right over there
click above to subscribe if you guys
want to see more videos to help us reach
our goal of 1 million subscribers we
would absolutely appreciate it that's
been max and i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]